hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
today's sunday you know what that means
that means i'm gonna be answering your
property
investment questions maybe you're
thinking but samuel leeds
what do you know about property you look
just so young and slim
maybe you're not thinking the slim part
but i've been in property for now 12
years
i bought my first house when i was 17.
i'm now 29
30 next year and i've done over 300
property deals
and i take all my experience condense it
and then answer your questions use my
knowledge my energy to help you out in
your journey so please do me a big favor
and just as a way of giving back and
showing your support
smash the like button and drop a comment
below not just a comment telling me
you know thank you for your videos
they're obviously really nice i like
those videos but i need your questions
your property investment questions
because without your questions
without your comments i have nothing to
talk about so you comment your questions
below around property investing
how you can become financially free the
next step if you've got niggly questions
and problems
you know if i'll do my best to help you
so comment below
in the meantime let me start answering
some questions from last sunday's video
uh wayne says simple buy now or buy
after christmas when we can
see more clearly where the market is
gonna be
i can see clearly now the rain is gone
listen you're never gonna know exactly
what's gonna happen okay
my advice would be buy but make sure
you're buying for
cash flow because if you say where's the
market going to be what you're basically
saying is if i buy a house is it going
to go up or is it going to go down
it's going to do both it's going to go
up it's going to go down
it's going to go around but ultimately
long term it's going to go up so you
need to make sure when you're buying
you're buying a property that's going to
produce monthly cash flow and profit for
you and then regardless if the property
goes up or down
you're still going to be in positive
every single month the definition of an
asset is something that puts money in
your back pocket every single month as
long as the property is doing that i
wouldn't worry too much
so general consensus would be don't
stress too much about what's about to
happen because we never know for sure
and those people that wait and wait and
wait and wait and wait end up doing
nothing so
just make sure you're buying for cash
flow that's my biggest advice next leo
says
if i have no income proof and bad credit
but have money inherited
and need to invest it what are the
chances of getting a buy to let before a
residential mortgage
so uh leo um you're gonna
probably struggle to get the best rates
if you've not got great credit you're
gonna it's gonna really limit the amount
of lenders that will lend to you
however you'd be surprised there are
still banks out there and mortgage
companies that will give you money
because if it's a buy to let property
they're more concerned with the property
than they're concerned about you because
what they want they're a bank they're a
lender they're giving you money
they need to know that you're going to
be able to pay the monthly repayments or
the interest payments
if it's a buy to let property they're
going to look at the property if it's
good
and they can see that it's very rentable
and you know buy low rent hi it's a good
property
well yielding property you know they're
going to be more open to it so
my advice would be to speak to a
mortgage advisor it might be
that you know for the first six months
maybe buy a little small property get a
bit of landlord experience get your
credit better
and then start scaling or joint venture
with someone who's got good credit
and put them on and use is called
tenants in common
where you put somebody else on the
mortgage with you you can always
refinance them off down the line
but there is a um you know it's very
possible the biggest
my biggest advice would be don't rule
yourself out it's easy to sometimes say
i'm too young i'm too old i've got bad
credit i've not got enough money but
there's always a way around it you know
so you've got to be creative
and uh let me know how you get on leo
great question if you're enjoying the
video
smash the like okay i've got another leo
currency this guy's called leopold a
different different person
uh hi simon just wondering what's the
reason why you rent your own house when
you buy houses
i rent my house because if i bought it
it's it's a big house okay multi-million
pound house
if i bought that house the amount of
money that i'd have to put down and tie
up in the house
and it wouldn't be an asset because it
wouldn't be putting money in my pocket
every month
i don't put lots of money in stuff that
aren't assets
so i'll rent where i live and i'll rent
out what i own that's just my philosophy
makes financial and business sense so
that's why
leo 2 says i'm a brit living abroad as
an expat
have some savings and invest in the
stock market but want to start investing
in property how can i
do what you do from outside the uk is
there anyway
yeah there is a way if you're living
overseas if you're an expat
it's all about having a good team around
you you're going to need to obviously
have a broker that can
find you that can get mortgages for you
so you need a good broker
you're also going to need someone uh
what are they called like a money mover
someone that can move your money from
one country to the other try and make
sure that you do it at a good time to
also make money
on the exchange rate so if you've got a
good team around you
also a good management team to manage
the property you absolutely can do
exactly what i do
for sure so yeah cow w
long time listener first time messaging
oh
okay so you've been listening for a long
time what took you so long cal
and also bother if you're watching this
and you watch my videos but you don't
normally comment
comment now do your first question below
and i'll try my best to answer
everyone's question
i'm looking to buy a hmo i understand a
real estate crash is looming
buy now and start collecting cash flow
or hold out for lower prices thanks so
much so again
similar question callum to uh the
question i had previously
and my advice would be this okay and i'm
only speaking from experience
because in 2009 when i had the same
doubts i was thinking should i buy now
shall i wait
everyone was telling me to wait but i
just thought you know what
i'm not waiting i'm buying now and i
bought now and yes properties dipped
but they bounce straight back up and now
those properties that i bought in 2009
2010
in a very bad uncertain time have
doubled in value
many of them some of them more than
doubled in value so i'd say the same
thing
buy in an area that's bottomed out don't
buy after a big rise
every area has its own mini economy so
find out
the economy the trends of the area
and you've got to hope for capital
appreciation but capital appreciation
doesn't pay the bills
rent cash flow pays the bills so just
make sure you're buying good make sure
you're buying good houses joe summer hi
samuel thanks for answering my question
about more complex roi i'm forever
grateful you're so welcome joe that's
what we do here man
my next question is what do you feel is
the best way to network with other
property investors while no networking
events are currently running with covid
also on the rise again many thanks joe
um joe you say that no networking events
are running on and people aren't getting
that's not true
i mean i'm networking every day i've got
events running
i'm doing things i'm at business
meetings i'm connecting
people are coming around my office i'm
running discovery days
in my home office with people training
them they're networking we're doing
joint ventures
we're running our academy events back on
we're running events regularly
for our academy students so in the
normal world
things might not be going on but you've
got to change your circle
you've got to get you've got to get
around people that are
it's very easy right now not to get out
the house
use covert as an excuse you can use
cover as an excuse for everything right
now
or you can use kobe as an opportunity to
get out in the in in the elite
property networks where you where you
have the eagles
you know so if you want to if you want
to come down to a discovery day by the
way meet me
face to face in person get to know me
i'll leave a link in the description
below for the discovery days where you
can come down to my home office they're
very very limited i only run
maximum of 10 people at a time and you
have to pay a fee and everything but you
can see the details be like
okay cameron johnson samuel when will
your courses such as the crash cost be
back
um our online courses during this time
all right
i don't want this to turn to a whole big
thing about my courses and me this is
about you and this is about property but
that's this last question about me and
my courses and i'm going to move on
and go back to property but um cameron
johnson to answer your question
i am running events i'm running
discovery days i'm running i
am i also i'm doing online stuff i'm
going to leave the descriptions in the
link
if you want to do training with me you
want to get mentored
i'll leave all the descriptions in the
link and let's get back to the questions
i hope that helps by the way if you like
these videos
smash the like button i'd really
appreciate that shazad butcher
hi samuel there's no help for new
developers
what kind of help you're looking for i
mean is this not help
is this not help geez that
anyway simple question
i'm about to embark on a small project
first time so a little scared
with the current economic climate should
i build or should i wait
if i if i wait due to recession do you
think the construction costs will be
cheaper
i'm not borrowing i'm investing my whole
life savings into this project
that's why i'm scared on the risks once
built i intend to pass it on to my kids
to help them onto the property ladder
please advise you're the expert what do
you think
shazad i'd be very very careful
the reason you're scared is because you
probably lack confidence
and the reason you lack confidence is
because you haven't got the knowledge
if you had the knowledge you wouldn't be
scared fear
usually comes from a lack of knowledge
if you're scared about something it's
because you don't know what the outcome
is going to be
if you are educated in an area like if
you if
if you're you know you're not scared
when you drive you drive a car you're
not scared
of course you might crash but you're
a good driver you're competent you're
confident and competent
so you drive with certainty not fear the
very first time you get in a car
you're scared especially if if if
you get a bit a bit speedy and a bit oh
you get scared because you haven't got
the confidence and competence so
before you spend your whole life savings
onto a big development build
i would say you got to get educated
you've got to get your confidence up
because the last thing i want you to do
is to blow it
and that can happen in development maybe
either start smaller
start with a little buy to let and get
some experience in property and and
and grow um or do this deal
but get a mentor i'll happily be your
mentor okay
for sure in the description but just get
someone to work with you look at the
deal
and make sure that this is going to work
and this is going to make money there's
always some risk but if you don't know
what you're doing
you massively massively massively
amplify that risk
so hope that helps hunter hunter beer
says
how to best structure integrating an
investor into a deal
do i put everything in my name and they
just transfer me the money
then we sort our cuts once the deal is
done
or do we have to be transparent with all
parties involved and declare the
investor all the way through
great question there's no right or wrong
way to do this
every joint venture agreement is always
done differently you could do it in your
name
you could do it in their name you could
set up a company and buy
in in both of your names and buy through
that company
you could if you go do it in there now
but listen what you should not do
is not just wing it and not have a
contract
so if you're doing it in your name which
is okay but they're putting the money in
there they might not mind that okay i've
done that
i've had projects with many projects
whereby i've put the money in and it's
actually been in someone's name
no problem but they're going to damn
well make sure
if they're putting all the money in that
they've got some kind of uh
first a contract to say that actually
although
this is in your name you've got a
contract to say that they're going to
get their money out and you're going to
split the profits however you decide to
split them
they're also going to want restriction
or charges on the property
so that you can't go you know i changed
my mind and just sell it
so even though it might be in your name
it's
on the title deeds it's going to have
charges restrictions
so so how you structure it really
depends on many things there's
depends on your tax if you're a high
right pay if they're a high rate payer
i'm very happy to do deals outside of my
name you know that's fine
but i know what i'm doing and i'll make
sure i have contracts and solicitors
different place
so um probably speak to an accountant
about that speak to speak to your
accountant and just see what's more tax
efficient
and also make sure you've got a good
solicitor on board and if you're doing
any kind of joint venture you need to
really make sure
that you've got clear roles and
responsibilities so you know
what's expected of one another and if
they're going to be putting in all the
money
they're probably going to expect you to
do all the work
you know that's what you're getting your
percentage split for so
but as i said joint venture agreements
are a blank piece of paper and every
joint venture is different
hope that helps nick hi samuel
if i can borrow the money from an angel
investor for the deposit
on a buy to let would i still get a
mortgage as i hear they
like you to have your own money as a
deposit so nick if you're buying a
standard buy to let mortgage and you're
getting a 75
budget mortgage they're going to want to
know where the deposit came from
and if you say it came from my mate over
here unless it's a gift
if it's a gift no problem but if you
tell them i just come from
my angel investor they're going to have
a problem with that and they're going to
have a problem with it because they're
going to say well
you're borrowing 75 from us 25
from the investor you have no skin in
the game for
for this project and they're not going
to like it so the way around it
is usually to structure the deal
differently so you're better off to buy
a property that needs a bit of work
and to buy it using bridging loan not a
mortgage
and your investors money you're going to
take bridging loan money your investors
money you're going to buy
bridging loans bridging companies don't
care where their deposit comes from
they're not bothered so you're going to
buy a bridging loan
investors money buy it no problems
you're then going to add value
as much as you can and then you're going
to re-mortgage
you're then going to get a new buy to
let mortgage on it by which point
they're not going to care who put the
money in or because
because it's already been bought and
you're going to then refinance and if
you play your cards right
and if you add enough value you should
if you get if you can if you do it right
be able to pull out all of the money
that you put in initially and pay off
the bridging company and
pay off the investor boom and be left
with a normally down deal
if you don't manage to do it you'll
still be able to pull out the vast
majority
that's called the buy refurbished
refinance strategy
combined with joint ventures so that
would be the way that i would do it i
hope that helps nick
great question by the way guys again if
you're enjoying this knowledge
i really try my best to answer these as
concise as possible to help you
give you the maximum input and value do
me a favor
smash the like button subscribe turn the
notification bell on
aurelle thanks for the great training
slightly unusual question
can you refinance a property that you
have a lease option agreement on
i.e you've agreed to have the option to
buy in seven years for 120
but you've done some refurb on it and
the values boosted to 150
can you refinance and pay the vendor now
instead of in seven years time
great question so if you've got a lease
option agreement on a property my advice
would be to
wait probably until the end not
generally speaking
before you buy the property um if you do
buy
earlier you will struggle
to get a mortgage on a lease option
agreement property because the lender
the lenders don't like it when you bring
a property to them and you say look i'm
buying this house
can i get a mortgage on it but you're
not refinancing it because it's not
yours yet
but you've had a previous interest in
the property and
lenders don't like that and it can cause
complications so the way to do it
there's a couple there's a few ways
around it but the way to do it is to
either set up a brand new company
called purple rain
limited or whatever you want to call it
let's have a brand new company
and then say to the owner hey owner i
know i've got an option to buy this
property for 120.
um but actually you know i'd like to buy
it now and i'm also i'm going to be
buying it in my company purple rain i
hope that's okay
now purple rain will then buy the
property
then when the lenders lend the money
they're not lending it to you they're
lending it to purple rain and it gets
around that conflict of interesting
another thing you can do is you can buy
it like i said a moment ago buying
borrowing getting bridging finance and
then angel investors money or whatever
and you can buy it that way or your own
money in bridging finance
but get a bridging loan to buy it
because again the bridging companies
don't care
and then do the works on the property
and then refinance it
that would be a smart way to do it i
don't know if that answered your
question exactly but i hope it helped
comment below and uh guys if you find
this helpful comment below
ask your questions as well if you get
spin-off questions when i'm answering
comment them below and i'll do my best
to answer and um good luck with your
lease option agreement
sabina alley hi i'm currently looking to
get a buy to let property for a maximum
of 55 000 pounds
i've been looking in hull area but
unsure what the rental market is
i was wondering if you think any other
areas would be good buy to let
investment i currently have a budget in
sheffield which i got three years ago
it's doing really well
however fifty five thousand pounds does
not go far in this area
um sabina i'd probably try and stick to
sheffield sheffield's a great area
and if you don't know the whole market
yeah hall's good
holly is good but you've with many
cities you've got
good and then you've got terrible
literally within quarter of a mile away
from each other so don't
buy in an area that you don't know if
you've already got a property to do
really well in sheffield
why not stick to sheffield what why why
does it need to be only 55 000 why can't
you do something higher
borrow more do a bigger deal bring so i
mean
i'd need to know more about your
situation but my advice would be sounds
to me like you're saving the money
you're working really hard saving it and
buying it and now you've got 55
you've got you've maybe you've got less
maybe you've got 10 grand you can only
put that towards a 55 grand house you
need to change your entire strategy
you need to be looking at least options
you need to be deal packaging you need
to be bringing in joint ventures you
need to be doing brr you need to change
your entire strategies might is my
opinion but stick in sheffield
i did my financial freedom challenge in
sheffield and absolutely bossed it it's
a great area
life of a marathon what's your opinion
on the five percent deposit rule
uncle boris has announced recently i
think it's great although we don't know
the full details yet but i think it
could be great
as long as you can rent the house out no
you won't be able to rip the house out
it's five percent right you're only
putting in five percent
don't buy a new build that's the sham
help to buy where you have to buy a new
building you have to live in it
i don't know enough details yet i had a
debate with russell about this
on my youtube channel um recently in
fact i put a little card you can see the
debate i had with russell
uh i i i we need more details was the
was the was the at the conclusion and
boris has not announced the details yet
but it's gonna be okay
it's gonna be okay big boss love your
videos mate just wanted to know
if you buy a house with the mortgage of
being interest only
how much tax do you have to pay and is
there a way of limiting the amount of
tax being paid
yeah if you buy a a house with the
mortgage of being interested only how
much tax you have to pay it depends how
you buy it
you know tax is such a a specific
question
if you buy a property as a buy to let
how much taxes you pay
if you buy it through a company the
interest mortgage payments you don't pay
tax on those
there's well it's sorry it's tax
deductible you can claim it back
if you buy it as an individual you're
gonna have to you're not gonna have to
claim the backs you're gonna pay more
due to section 24. if you're buying a
house
to rent it a serviced accommodation
you're not going to pay any
you're not going to section 24 won't
apply so you're about to claim the
mortgage payments back
so it depends how you buy it um
i don't know if i could be much more
helpful than that at this point in time
maybe do a follow-up question that'd be
great
ryan morgan i'm currently just finishing
my second property which in the middle
of switching to buy to let ready to move
someone in the house
my first house was a flip which i loved
but
but look at things a lot different after
watching your videos with brrs
i earned 50 000 pound return on my first
flip but now looking to build a
portfolio
but 20 deposits on my next purchase how
do i get around this
dude you just interview brr br if you've
done a flip successfully made 50 grand
brl's the same thing
the only advantage to to doing a bro
instead of a flip
is a flip is buy refurb sell take your
money
pay tax on that money capital gains tax
whereas by a brr a burr is by
refurbish don't sell refinance
pull your money back out that's tax free
man
you don't pay tax on debt you then
reinvest that money
and you got cash flow coming in because
you rent the property out so it's a very
similar strategy
okay ryan lewis
when a limited company buys a
residential property to fix and flip
do they have to pay stamp duty when
buying if so what percentage
okay so it depends stamp duty if you're
buying 100
house as a buy to let you typically pay
about 3 000 pounds about 3
and as it gets bigger and bigger and
bigger the scale can go up it goes up a
little bit as a sliding scale um
if you're buying it there's a fix and
flip if it's
if the property is not habitable to live
in if there's no hot water and no
kitchen and bathroom
you won't pay stamp duty so with fixed
and flips you want to make sure that
you're speaking to your solicitor before
you buy the house but make sure that you
don't i wouldn't want to be paying tax
stamp duty tax if i'm doing the property
up i'm going to be wanting to try and
find properties that are on
uh unmortgageable whereby i won't pay
stamp duty so speak to your sister on
that one and try and avoid it
um all right last question last question
michael says you're a good man samuel
leeds i appreciate that thank you so
much me and my family we love you so
much and may the lord honor you with a
long
and healthy life oh i appreciate that
i'm going to end on that note thank you
so much what a great comment
uh i appreciate it i do a video every
single day folks on youtube
and i appreciate the not kind comments i
appreciate the questions
and um you know keep the questions
coming i'm going to keep answering them
i hope you found this video useful
if you did smash the like button drop a
question below
also if you asked a question i'm
probably going to answer your question
next week
not definitely but i'm going to answer a
load of them next week the last thing
you want to happen
is you type a question in and then you
don't see the video
and then a few weeks later you come back
and you've lost it so make sure you do
subscribe okay
i'll put a subscribe button right here
there we go subscribe click that
thing right there turn the notification
belt on if you want to do some training
or some mentoring want to come down to
my home office
i'll leave the link in the description
where you can get more training and i
look forward to seeing your next video
peace out thanks for watching